ça ne m'étonne pas tout simplement et je
pense que ça n'a étonné personne
mais c'est bien pour ça que ça pas fait
beaucoup de buzz ça n'a étonné personne
veut dire mathieu c'est le poison
incarner je pense qu'il va avoir un vrai
mal être en lui pour diffuser autant de
concours de lui je pense que demain à
faire à ce que des filles
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on a déjà le
seul perdre à nice et qui peut dire que
mathieu n'a pas de poison lui alors je
sais pas moi je
moi je le dis n'est jamais venu en moi
je ne veux pas connaître son poisson il
a longuement essayé mais non c'est bien
la société en fait mathieu il a vraiment
un rapport au matériel qui est malsain
et un coup de cocheur
[Rires]
turkestan pense parce que tu es toi
aussi tu as un poison lent mais moi déjà
je trouve que vraiment c'est on a le
droit de s'exprimer on a le droit d
gratuit à ses opinions et en aucun cas
la haine qui a suivi a pas de haine
balle et on va laisser mama tu répondes
après parce que je voudrais faire un
petit tour donc d'altitude ils n'ont pas
ce qui n'est pas étonné parce que ça
t'étonne pas que mathieu non mais non
mais en fait oui je suis je suis pas
étonné parce que mathieu rêve d'être
comédien alors que c'est peut-être d'ici
ce fait si je me fais virer il peut
prendre ma place ça se trouve la
perruque bleue ça lui va très bien mais
manque de pot je suis pas virer donc les
seuils pour l'année prochaine enfin
voila je sais pas quoi de dire je trouve
ça tellement au sort tu me fait pitié en
fait
il ya deux choses que tu aimes tu es pas
vraiment la démission de
mambé nordine s'appellerait des choses
qu'elle m'aime pas elle a pris en grippe
j'aime l'argent et tu t'aime toi même
c'est une m version demande qu'est ce
qui t'arrive excuse moi je serai
palladium sortie
sabotage pas pourquoi mais mais d'où
peut venir autant de méchanceté et
pourtant dieu sait que j'ai jamais eu de
méchanceté envers toi donc ton mépris il
vient d'où en fait je crois qu'ils ont
alors mathieu parce que clairement quand
même je me suis j'ai contacté des
avocats donc je peux porter plainte
contre x pour diffamation et injures
publiques pour nos losail en plus
alors cette année serait adapté du
terrain ce n'est pas ce que
ça l'a blessé match était déjà demandé
plein de fois j'ai dit allons manger
ensemble 6 à machin sur alençon si tu
payes en
mauricie a payé moi j'ai vraiment c'est
moi qui sors ta carte bleue quand je
vais manger à quelqu'un j'ai pas de
problème hautement gens sont morts la
dernière fois je vous ai invité
d'ailleurs oui on est plus
et donc du coup à lyon chez moi
[Rires]
donc du coup mathieu dis moi tout
simplement qu est ce que je t'ai fait
pour que tu m'aimes est-ce que tu as vu
qu'il ya déjà eu un déferlement les gens
n'ont pas compris parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens comme toi qui
comprennent pas ce que je dis qu'ils
comprennent pas ce que dit arthur était
obligé de me rajouter comme ça pas vous
avez bâti la même chose tout en même
temps on n'a pas directement dm chose
sur le fond sur le fond ils ont dit la
même chose qui n'est jamais allée qui
divergent
voilà c'est ça autrement et on a envie
d'innocence est ici et si je connais mi6
dans cette émission interactive la forme
c'est que tout le monde a le droit de
s'exprimer voilà on est là on est on est
on est dans la tolérance non mais c'est
vrai voilà c'est ça que j'aime voilà il
demain voilà on fera cette émission sur
delphine at elle est exécutée ma télé
voilà et séoul sera où les sons dans le
faire on le fera
oui gilles verdez bon alors moi ce qui
m'a gêné mathieu c'est l'allusion à
dieudonné très franchement là vous avez
dépassé les bornes dieudonné s'est quand
même condamnation pour injures
antisémites provocation à la haine
contestation de crimes contre l'humanité
là je trouve que vous auriez dû retirer
ensuite je vais vous le dire sincèrement
je trouve que la delphine
je donne raison à mathieu en retirant
dieudonné sur l'ensemble de ce qu'il a
dit donc pour une fois je retourne ma
pancarte ah ouais parce que là où c'est
pourquoi pas parce que la saisine en mai
c'est le roi qui l'a nommé par lui était
le premier album à berlin deuxième on a
voulu lui accorder toute liberté
d'expression c'est formidable on a le
droit à la moindre erreur me daquo votre
problème à mon problème c'est pas mon
problème c'est qu'elle conteste la même
chose à mathieu t elle remis à mathieu
le droit de s'exprimer mais à les
entendre
il a collé là il la conçoit radio
toujours donné vous aimez moi c'est moi
ouais mais tu peux pas dire voilà si la
lah sur les ventes à la loi hugo
non mais moi pour moi le vrai problème
c'est que mathieu dieudonné fins et
c'est un comparatif que tu ne peux pas
faire c'est vraiment le coeur du sujet
c'est de comparer à dieudonné en fait
une fait que renforcer l'idée que les
gens qui votent et quittent la droite
ils sont tous des fous comme ça parce
qu'à ce moment il ya eu comparaison
quand il va comment manier le coup
paramètres aussi dieudonné dans une
émission à quelle est cette action non
mais bon c'est pas pour les moules et
une allusion à mettre des gens qui ont
dépensé à mon sens extrême comme elle ne
l a pas d'efforts section si vous
répondez tout seul à la réponse extrême
je tenais je dis que je ne le droit le
conseil qui serait horaire avant que son
père et sa mère pour l'eau en europe
sont bons et ce à la défense a les
moyens mais en les faisant passer pour
aller voir le match s'est joué les
matchs où ils allaient faisant passer
pour des monstres tu ne fait que
renforcer mais cyril je m'arrêtais la
mascotte et vos thèses fils thomas maire
qui n'ait qui n'est plus là j'ai du
poison à moi je suis une merde je le
pense aussi je pensais qu'ils auraient
un petit débat de fond ggd
je marque mais la raison la soliste je
m'attelle à deux ans que je roule à dès
que je parle mathieu oui on n'est pas là
mais en fait c'est un règlement de
compte personnel
sans parler du foot mais mme dati
peut-être qui éventuellement j'en sais
rien tu ne m'aimes pas tu étais raison
si je ne l'aimais pas peut-être que
jamais raison mais c'est pas moi j'ai
mis ça les fans de l'émission a été un
amour j'aime bien mais voilà je vendrai
la maman d'un petit message sur quel
accueil ça qui me coûte plus cher que
d'autres violences tu as marqué oui elle
doit pas partir non mais je marie stella
jugé plus débat avec toi ça va je ne
prendrai pas ma mère et je sais plus ce
que tout ça va s'arrêter là et du poison
et je sais pas moi de m'arrêter là
delphi moi tellement méchant je
m'arrêter là debout quoique tellement
méchant à bâle avec les autres ah bah
non alors moi je pensais qu'on
discuterait un peu du fond j'ai du
poison je suis une merde je veux être
comédien je vendrai ma mère qui est
morte dans les six mois à m'arrêter là
ah voilà une histoire ok mais là c'est
pour ce débat valérie bal des trucs
d'accord non mais au-delà de là le
problème c'est que vous êtes vous parler
de quelque chose que l'été je sème leur
accueil n'ont rien à faire sur votre
inimitiés exactement ça vous dit c'est
une émission de télé non mais c'est vrai
désormais on parle on parle on parle de
cette histoire nicolas est une excuse de
positions qu'il avait prises de position
alain alain comme à l'oral à laon et
assure un débat moi je pense que sur ce
débat et je sais que j'aime mature mais
je le lui ai dit le jury et le jour j
quand il l'a quand il a évoqué de
données pour moi ça n'avait pas lieu
d'être en revanche effectivement tu lui
dénie le droit d'avoir une réflexion il
a le droit de penser que tu n'avais tu
ne peux pas être sur fort boyard ce
n'est pas ce que je pense mais s'il a
dit que le penser
car c'est delphine tous les domaines
c'est toi qui en a c'est pas moi ma
seule pensée c'était qu' il n'y a pas
une ode on ne doit pas mettre de
politique dans fort boyard point barre
dans une mission qui regardait alors des
n'y a pas d'autorité en fait de faire un
truc points
alors aidez mazarinades je sais que ça
chez les deux tigres ont été écartés
parce qu'ils vont également
tenir la jeune à la wii wii madania mais
c'est un faux procès ça la politique on
donne notre avis tourner l'année sur
plein de choses mais là justement c'est
parce qu'elle a pris parti pour marine
le pen que ça dérangeait pas vrai c'est
pour ça qu'on est bien sûr que si
c'est quand même maintenant mais les
choses essayer de la comparaison avec
dieudonné elle est pas innocente non
plus elle et moi j'ai trouvé ça très
violent et très très injuste parce que
elle jamais on ne peut être on pourrait
taxer des films de racisme dans ce
qu'elle a dit en tout cas ici je la
connais pas d'aigreur et seniors mais
alors moi j'en parle enchaînements
dansés la bbc jaya hockey y avait au
commerce a comme son avis dans tête
dentée pmp elle donne pas son avis de
fort boyard dans ces cas là vous draguez
soit viré tp mpm et puis qu'elles
aillent bosser à fort boyard tu crois
que le perçoivent au premier
blu-ray mélenchon
dans la solidarité encore fait de penser
que c'est difficile à fait d'accord tu
vas tu as de victimiser là comme ça les
raisons en prendre je voulais définir un
texte
je ne regarde jamais réseauter le film
mais peut-être même si elle ne savait
pas que cette histoire je ne regarde pas
les réseaux je ne lis pas je rentre chez
moi le choix je mange des pâtes et je me
couchais son quart est avec victimiser
les réseaux situe pas une marionnette tu
vas tu arrives on devait débattre
maintenant tu devais débat tu arrives tu
m'insultes possible et ce aux platines
et mathieu avec dalkia mathieu aulas dit
non mais s'il te plaît s'te plaît je
regarde pas les réseaux chez moi
j'essaie de digérer j'étais dans une
tempête de vent avaient mangé quoi une
tempête de fou mais détrompez vous savez
tous que c'était super qui perd
difficile et que si j'étais pas un peu
verrouillé et ben je sais pas ça passe
et c'était vraiment horrible c'était
vraiment horrible mois abandonnée c'est
tranquille je vous regarde et je sais
pas sur l'émission j'ai pas loin d'y
être et là je vois que on reparle de moi
ok je vois que tout tous les gens autour
prennent me défendre et la même toit et
franchement j'étais super content je
voulais même temps envoyé un petit mot
parce qu'on avait parlé en plus à
personne tout âge et au dernier moment
je m'estime à [ __ ] le mec tu tournes
ton truc et pas juste pour dire une
petite phrase tu tournes tout mais je
dis mais j'ai quand visiblement c'est du
poison et je tenais quel est le seul qui
t'a consoler le soir où tu avais pleuré
dans cette émission et elle est très bas
quel est le seul qu'elle était dehors
avec toi pour te parler quel est le seul
qui soit garçon qui a du poison ça ça
garçon qu'il vendrait sa mère ça
pourquoi ce qu'elle voit en gueule tout
le temps quand je parle pourquoi est-ce
que tu contredit tout le temps tous pour
toi c'est parce que
l alcool question au delà
la latte et hors sujet là des louis d'or
sujet excuse moi tu es hors sujet jeune
fille n'est pas ce que tu
fous là territoire à comparer à
quelqu'un qui est n'ai rien contre toi
de la menace et la ccal à celle des
bassesses enfin j'ai j'en avais déjà cgt
déjà submergées pourquoi est-ce que tu
as d'urgence mettre là ça c'est une
bonne question aucun malade de ce que
j'ai demandé un avocat ce est ce ma
personne je la connais pas mais cette
personne quand tu web mais on n'est pas
là pour raconter notre vie 2 tu m'as tu
vu un jour et tu m'a dit un jour j'avais
j'avais des chaussures bleu tu m'as dit
j'aime pas les chaussures on fait un
plein mais c'est bien pour ça que en
france on parle que dans cette histoire
qui s'est effectivement ce n'est pas que
de la télé c'est aussi des relations
humaines et quand on aime bien quelqu'un
on ira plus facilement dans son sens et
quand on on l'a du mépris et ben
bizarrement on ira piqué et je pense que
quelqu'un qui avait de l'affection ou
qu'ils avaient un minimum de respect ne
m'aurait jamais comparer à dieudonné
vendre histoire quand j'étais chez moi
en train de pleurer devant ma télé et en
a rajouté une couche pourquoi t'as fait
ça qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour que tu
fasses ça honnêtement d'affilée je pense
pas que ce soit contre toi je pense que
ça aurait pu être quelqu'un d'autre
c'est que mathieu aussi je me permets
mais mathieu a une façon un petit peu
provocante aussi de dire les choses et
de
valoriser un très bon trotteur il est
allé trop loin non mais jusqu'où sa
moitié enfin j'ai écrit match ultime
dans le truc mathieu mathieu je vais
vous dire mathieu donner son avis sur
fort boyard comme tout le monde c'était
le seul à dire non d'ailleurs ces jours
là oui non il a dit oui donc oui les
autres ont dit non voilà donc été
évacués et malade j'en ai besoin de buzz
non mais mathieu aujourd'hui elle est la
seule question que qui est intéressante
dans sa quête eu à poser pourquoi c'est
pourquoi l'avoir embarras dieudonné
voilà c'est tout si ils posaient les
lyonnais sont avisés que dans fort
boyard toiture présenter la pureté et
cetera que ça le génie de voir cette
année sans ces messages et le débat est
né là non mais c'est pas genre tu m'aime
pas et je t'aime et jette moi je ne
parlent jamais politique c'est
comprenait des citoyens maire d'alors
politique commence
oui c'est sûr pendant une période
exclusivement des présidentielles donc
tu as beau rigoler mais en fait c'est
que même là tu me fais rire se parlent
jamais politique l'autre chose mais je
parle politique quand on pose la
question géopolitique pendant le temps
souvent là maintenant je suis maintenant
la présidentielle est terminée c'est
clos c'est fini on a un président il ya
aucun problème donc moi je ne parlerai
plus j'aime vraiment vraiment j'ai envie
d'avoir tourné viennent chez moi c'est
toi c'est celui qui reste le voile avec
tout le monde le plus mathieu ont comme
mathieu on connaît on sait comment il
parle sur l'exemple de dieudonné la
comparaison bien évidemment que je ne
suis pas parce que dieudonné là il a il
a free il a passé plein de frontières
c'est il a été beaucoup plus loin que
delphine et je te souhaite de jamais
multi compta
directrice oui je te souhaite de ne pas
aller dans les landes et même si rodez
si j'ai voté blanc mais votez pour macro
je pense au gil a gelé tous et en soit
je vais pas refaire de la politique j'ai
juste voté l'opposition pour toutes les
personnes qui ont souffert pendant cinq
ans et j'aimerais que ça reste là dessus
ne chante pas ce que j'ai pu le voter je
voulais juste qu'on change je voulais
j'aimerais juste qu'on qu'on fasse
quelque chose d'autre en politique
maintenant ma foi on repart pour cinq
ans il n'y a pas de problème moi je
super vindicative j'ai pas ma carte
nulle part je voulais juste pendant ce
temps que c'était le sujet le sujet
était brûlant on pouvait choisir les
français ont choisi ya pas de problème
et pourquoi encore me mettre ça sur le
dos j'en dis bon alors d'abord moi je
voudrais dire que j'adore mathieu pour
moi il est extraordinaire et je suis
absolument d'accord avec toutes ses
prises de position de bonne conscience
de donneurs de leçons comme moi voilà ça
c'est la première chose alors alors et
je pense que monsieur l'on n'oublie pas
cette fois non c'est moi
qui pensais pourtant c'est moi j'irai
après je pense très liée à des contrats
qui doit être signé jeudi
ça va tomber comme un couperet ce qu'on
ne mesure pas le tsunami intersidéral
qu'avec une belle fille c'est vrai
examen je me souviens que je te l'avais
dit et tu avais dit ouais non mais je
t'avais dit qu'il avait eu du courage
parce qu'encore une fois je le répète
quelqu'un de médiatique comme toi de
connu comme toi qui passe à la télé tous
les soirs comme toi qui a été miss franc
comme toi ça ne va pas ça n'a jamais
existé dans le paysage audiovisuel
français et dans le paysage médiatique
français que tu le veuilles ou non alors
tu vas aujourd'hui tu fais un peu du
moonwalk du rétropédalage parce que je
pense que c'est très dur et parce que tu
en a pris plein la gueule mais voilà non
mais c'est à la petite cuillère dans le
couloir campait pleurait mais c'est
mathieu et mathé édité la hausse
après m'être poignard alors quand tu dis
que c'est un poison désaccord cette
sortie moi j'ai pas vu lille je vis
d'accord
c'est un truc de tennis il faut arrêter
de regarder tout le temps les réseaux
sociaux faut arrêter de faire de la télé
pour voir les réseaux sociaux tu fais tu
donnes ton avis donne son habitat donné
son avis et ses essais respectable il
donne son ami comme il donne son avis et
moi tu vois ce qui m'attriste là c'est
de savoir qu'on peut faire une émission
de télé et qu'après il ya des gens qui
vont voir des mois je tombe d'un nuage
on va voir des avocats moi je viens ici
pour rigoler je viens pas ici pour
qu'après un mec me dit j'ai été voir un
avocat portable moi je suis allée
conduire pour porter plainte contre la
portière de ce qu'on
pouvait faire ses propres exacte et
c'est une forme je te dirai oui les
forces de dire ce que le mandat qu'elle
s'était les recours et une force d'être
tous différent ici et c'est un bonheur
des thèmes différents et tu apprends que
par contre tu vas dire un truc et on va
peut-être aller se renseigner auprès des
avocats écoute il a dit ce qu'ils
pensaient d'ailleurs c'est comparer ma d
été de regarder les réseaux sociaux
c'est que ça c'est relou avec sa robe
est ce qu'on a dit en
mai même si on n'a pas envie de regarder
ça vient nous pour delphine si je puis
me permet des films malgré tout c'est
que effectivement elle a dit quand même
que c'était la maman des français
qu'elle avait envie de voter pour marca
buren et que ça pourrait revendre et
emma leurs visages sont arrêtés
mélenchon il aurait dit c'est la maman
dès la phase arrêtée castaldi elle
aurait dit c'est la maman des fusées que
magnifique poitrine bien je ne le crois
pas qu'elle aurait dit ça je peux me
tromper mais c'est pas le sujet en
revanche quand pardon vincent lindon qui
le président aujourd'hui 2
nativel de cannes qui dit qu'ils votent
pour jean luc mélenchon ça ne pose aucun
problème à personne et malgré tout
marine le pen aujourd'hui elle a eu le
plus de gens qui votent pour elle que
jean luc mélenchon donc je pense se
jouer à touche oui mais on ne peut pas
diaboliser les gens ont peut pas leur
faire perdre leur boulot on peut pas
leur faire un vrai problème aujourd'hui
de dédicaces et ce par rapport à ces
gens-là et j'aimerais même si je ne
partage pas les idées de delphi lequel
ne perd pas son boulot son tard ces
contrats parce que je trouve que sur ce
match des finales à domicile nice et
tous étaient admissibles si sa ket ces
contrats et donc j'ai une admission on a
tout juste à mon psy ne s est comble au
port après le vaccin oui
[Rires]
en dix ans assure sur des finances
actuelles j'ai prise et énergie permet
à
un mathieu tu es tu et à blesser
delphine les tuer blesser aussi beaucoup
d'autres gens comme on l'a dit l'autre
jour tuer tout le monde enfin le ce qui
fait la magie sont pas des racistes et
qui a été très très loin et lorsque
j'aimerais savoir c'est aujourd'hui avec
le redis est-ce que tu regrettes d'abord
c'est
exact des batteries plus donc c'est
en effet à millas avec cyril mais je
vais tout donner sur mais aviez tout
démarre et on a tout donné on a démarré
un débat avec du poison pas quelqu'un
parce que mathieu n'a pas de poison ici
il veut mon pays de mon métier il
vendresse la mer et
enfin l'histoire et franchement je sais
que j'ai pas bon a souvent quitté le
plateau je le quitte pas par politesse
bah oui mais je me tais terminé donc ne
me pose pas de questions
de l'homme c'est du poison et qu'elle
ait récupéré dans ses bras on n'est pas
des réseaux où je réfléchis donc j'ai
dit à mathieu et poison à dieu en disant
ça je dis vraiment je te remercie de
m'avoir fait un clin d'oeil en comparant
à des données merci beaucoup mathieu tu
es mon ami mais ce qui est à deux
rangées delfino de la vidéo de l'année
ronis quitte à déranger de la jamaïque
vient de dire cessé en a plus que deux
personnages il vient dire oui mais
mathieu delphine
c'est quoi si on perd ça mais qu'est ce
que tu racontes comme la belgique dans
des dépositions pas le net jeudi qu il a
une façon de faire clos comme une
personnalité c'est pour ça qu'on lève on
l'aimé comme ça où la noire il est si on
n'arrête pas de dire c'est une agora est
toutefois c'est pire une agora la place
publique
commence à y adhérer
ici le cnra teaser
se dire et tout peut s'entendre donc ok
il a il ya eu une une fragmentation ce
qui est là qui est le quai d'avoir
convoqué dieudonné bac mais si on enlève
à révocation à bulles donner le reste il
a le droit de le penser elle a le droit
de ne pas être d'accord et ils ont
laissé justement ici le lieu où quand on
n'est pas d'accord on s'affole pas et on
dialogue on parle justement de cette
phrase c'est moi qui dois m'excuser
marche normale celle qui l'a dit c'est
vraiment mais non non non non monde à
l'envers c'est le monde à l'envers moi
je pensais qu'il allait me dire bah je
sais pas j'ai dit ça parce que je t'aime
pas où j'ai dit ça ou alors je me sens
mais rien du tout ici comme il n'était
pas là dedans j'ai eu besoin d'être en
colère tu sais pas ça fait deux semaines
et et tu sais pas tu sais pas parce que
t'as jamais pris le temps de m'écrire
n'a jamais pris le temps de m'écrire et
et est d'ailleurs de répondre parce que
tu étais gréement même pams écoute et de
décrire de quoi je te demande juste
pourquoi est ce que tu as fait ça est ce
que tu a réfléchi une seule seconde à ce
que je pouvais penser fait ressentir
parce que la terrisse que j'aime les
gens là ici voilà et mathieu qui
s'échappe mais non parce que
les grosses conditions très macho je me
trouve brochette de tout arrive là tu
parles de poison de machin de moquette
images à l'époque litois autre image ap
tandis que quand tu me lance comme ça eh
bien eh ben ça reste pas sur le net et
de ta besoin de moi pour sur une image
mais maintenant mais par exemple que tu
pourrais supporter les bleus
dit il voulait faire quelque chose
mais c'est vrai ferme la ferme là oui
oui turquie veulent août la vraie pas en
parler mais c'est quand il veut dire
quoi leur ai parlé à des mobilisations
tout
arrive à dire oui delphine honnêtement
je trouve que vous avez tort la d'hyper
personnaliser le débat c'est à dire que
dix ans fc nantes pour moi c'était pour
moi sans mais pas pourquoi mais c'est
moi j'ai déjà ces trois mots c'est pas
la peine c'est à dire que là vous êtes
sur l'amitié l'inimitié la confrontation
personnelle etc c'est un ami mais c'est
ça et c'était je ne dirai jamais saint
avold importe on est sur le débat
d'idées ici on est sur la confrontation
et nokia fond du trou mais lui il a
juste rajouté une pelletée dessus mais
pensez aux idées on sait aussi des mois
je vous ai défendu le droit d'exprimer
vos aînés quelle qu'elle soit et cette
finale et vérifier parce qu'il a il a
comparé les données
cvs cjo belle fille lui ai juste comme
ça n ya qu a le droit aussi de
s'exprimer là là vous êtes en train
d'établir une chanson infernale et
arrêter de penser que c'est contre vous
delphine c'est contre ce que vous avez
dit ne venez pas ça trop à coeur et wc
sinon mais vous éloignez vous de votre
image sur les réseaux qui sont bons
c'est mon coco qu'est ce que ça veut
dire gilles qu'en fait alors maintenant
on oublie que c'est mathieu et on oublie
c'est de le fermer oui je veux dire que
tu vous trouvez ça normal de comparer
quelqu'un qui dit qu'elle va peut-être
essayer marine le pen à des propos qu'a
tenus dieudonné qui est condamné mais
disent que quand c'est
delphine et monsieur simplement atig tu
me fatigues vraiment tu sais pourquoi
parce que le moindre sujet un petit
sujet ridicule au bout d'un moment on a
le grand gilles verdez qui dit
inadmissible vous devriez connaître
la loi s'applique on à la poste on n'a
pas la super g moi je sais chérie j'ai
envie de terminer mes chaussures ça
et là c'est au keeper grave et et étudie
rien merci jean agressions des nations
alors on s'est réveillé lors les chéris
voilà parce que je ne soigne et voilà
que vous consommez en plus mathieu
delphine ça allait mieux les deux c'est
vrai bien mais c'est avec widi jeter bas
on est une famille et c'est vrai que
voilà il ya des dans la famille on a qui
s'aiment bien à qui sait moins mais en
revanche torres parler très sympa ce que
parce que voilà ce que je vois justement
7,7 l'avocat josh cohen ans avec tous
mais très sincèrement moi la faille que
je vois je laime et moi je comprends pas
voilà même est entendue il ya des
étudiants afin que tu allais ce soir
mais je vais juste j'ai mangé de la
bienveillance comme tout le monde et
même pour toi est ce que tu m'as donné
la dernière fois dans le dans le couloir
j'ai vraiment apprécié c'est pour ça que
j'ai pas compris ça j'étais déjà très
très mal et tu le sais et vous voulez
pas vous faire un petit bisou il est
aussi là
[Applaudissements]
oui je n'en passera vraiment pas non non
non pas ce soir mais ça je te bouffe le
nom de the other
ce soir non non on laisse un petit peu
déjanté voilà je mets elle même pas
voilà
me demande katé mé na coeur on peut
faire l'émission peut-être que vous
pourrez vous arrangez pour qu'on fasse
des émules et non à l autre ce soit même
temps plein ne demande qu à timmins
haider médias